t'avais qu'à augusta lunar dix
journalistes indépendants dont trois ou
deux talonneurs dit merci d'être avec
nous on vient de le dire le brésil
troisième pays le plus touché
concrètement quelle est la situation
sanitaire sur place ou à la situation
est des plus en plus inquiétante
en 72 heures nous sommes passés de la
sixième à la troisième position en
nombre d'infectés du coville 19
on compte officiellement que de 250 mais
cas confirmés dépassant la france même
le royaume uni le nombre de décès
dépasse désormais les 17000 et nous
avons aussi la plus forte mortalité
quotidienne enregistrée en dehors des
états unis
des chercheurs du centre qu'ovide sont
alarmistes car selon les chiffres
officiels pourraient dépasser 15 fois
que je les chiffres qui sont
officiellement communiquée donc on
aurait entre 2 et 3 millions de cas
confirmés au brésil où la conséquence
sur la santé des brésiliens est visible
nous faisons face à un chaos sanitaire
surtout dans la région le système de
santé plus précaires et les lits en
unité de soins intensifs sont quasiment
tous occupés dans quelques états du nord
du pays une région amazonienne et même
dans des grandes villes comme rio dé
janeiro
donc je ne sais pas si nous serons
peut-être le prochain épicentre de la
contagion et dans tous les cas nous nous
approchons de plus en plus du scénario
nord américain quelle est la situation
dans les hôpitaux on a parlé en europe 1
en italie dans le grand est
au début de l'épidémie de ce tri
terrible en trop les malades est ce
qu'on en est là aussi dans certains
endroits au brésil oui exactement dans
la ville de man house est la plus grande
ville de la région amazonienne
c'est déjà le cas les lits en unité de
soins intensifs sont déjà très occupés
pendant qu'ils sont aimés en sont
obligés de choisir qui ils vont traiter
ce n'est pas encore le cas dans d'autres
régions du pays comme 100 par l'eau ou
alors dans le sud mais la situation est
très inquiétant parce que nous n'avons
pas encore atteint le pic de la maladie
et on ne sait pas à quoi s'attendre dans
les prochaines semaines parce que la
situation de la santé du système de
santé brésilien est déjà au bord de la
saturation et donc la prévision pour les
prochaines semaines et de d'un chaos
total
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de pauvreté au
brésil quel est le profil des victimes
du duc o vie de 19 aces qu'à l'instar
d'autres pays elles touchent souvent les
minorités oui exactement ce qu'on sait
c'est que la plus de la moitié des
personnes décédées à cause du nouveau
coronavirus sont noirs ou métis dont la
plupart est issu des classes
défavorisées
ces personnes n'ont pas d'assurance
maladie il s'expose davantage aux
risques du virus car ils sont obligés de
continuer de travailler
ils ont du mal à s'isoler chez eux quand
quelqu'un de leur famille est malade il
faut savoir aussi que plus de 13
millions de brésiliens habitent dans les
favelas brésiliennes et leurs maisons
sont imbriquées les unes sur les autres
il ya parfois plus de huit ou neuf
personnes qui habitent dans une seule
pièce donc et souvent ils n'ont pas de
services sanitaires de base
il est donc impossible pour ces gens de
suivre les consignes sanitaires de le
msp est aussi il y à une autre minorité
qui est menacée par ce nouveau courant
d'un virus
ce sont les peuples autochtones qui
vivent une situation extrêmement
inquiétante aujourd'hui plus d'une
centaine d' indigènes ou résilience mort
du co v19 ça paraît pas beaucoup mais ça
pourrait augmenter énormément dans les
prochaines semaines et ces communautés
sont extrêmement vulnérables plus que
nous aux maladies urbaine et aussi aux
maladies et aux épidémies venus de
l'extérieur et sans parler du fait
qu'ils habitent souvent dans des régions
isolées qui sont à des milliers de
kilomètres des centres de santé alors on
voit l'attitude pour le moins
surprenante du président bolle sonar au
qui persiste dans son coronas
scepticisme comment l'expliquer ce déni
est ce qu'il est réel ce qu'ils aient
faim alors il est difficile d'expliquer
ce qui se passe dans la tête de jay
molson arômes et dans tous les cas il
n'a pas changé de position a déplu le
début de l'épidémie continue de
minimiser le virus de dire que c'est une
petite grippe il a déjà dit à de
nombreuses reprises que c'était une
exagération une hystérie
des médias et il n'a pas changé de
comportement depuis il maintient son
discours et 2 continuent de demander à
la population brésilienne de continuer
de travailler de continuer d'aller
dehors il dit que le brésil pendant que
le cours d'un virus ferait plus de mal
au porte-monnaie des brésiliens qui à
leur santé il a aussi pris l'habitude
ces derniers temps de participer à des
manifestations pro gouvernement à
brasilia qui prône la suppression du
parlement et de la cour suprême et qui
demande aussi parfois des interventions
militaires et donc les participants avec
l'homme aussi l'application de la halle
c'est un décret le plus dur les plus
violents de la dictature militaire
brésilienne donc suite à cette mauvaise
gestion
face à l'épidémie est aussi à sa
participation à ces manifestations qui
sont considérées comme anti démocratique
de plus en plus de voix s'élèvent de
parlement brésilien pour demander la
destitution de parts de boltzmann araud
mais pour l'instant rien n'a été fait on
verra dans les prochaines semaines vous
dites de plus en plus de monde on a
entendu le l'ancien président lula a
parlé de génocide d'irresponsabilité
effectivement à ce que l'opinion
brésilienne est en train de prendre la
mesure de ces paroles effectivement un
petit peu étonnant de la part du
président qui peut les mettre clairement
en danger alors la population est
divisée
le dirais que la moitié des brésiliens
continue de suivre bolton 1re soit parce
qu'ils dépendent du commerce informel 40
millions de brésiliens dépendre de ça
pour travailler pour continuer de vivre
une autre partie de la population défend
aveuglement les propos de bol sonar ou
et pense que cette épidémie n'existe pas
ou alors que l'économie est plus
importante
et l'autre moitié de brésiliens et
complètement confinés chez eux
les gens sont extrêmement inquiets et
craignent une hécatombe et ils
manifestent tous les soirs réligieuses
mans je dirais devant leurs fenêtres
en tapant sur des casseroles pour
demander la destitution de de bolton a
road on colle à la l'opinion publique
est plus divisé que jamais
on ne fait que s'empirer cette folie
polarisation aux politiques ne fait
qu'empirer
merci à vous stallone a redit en direct
donc du brésil